[Music]
there are different definitions of
architecture defined by different
organizations in UML the unified
modeling language it's the collection of
connected units which are organized to
accompany specific purpose and what you
need is some kind of model which defines
how these things interconnect the I
Triple E says a system is a collection
of components which need to be organized
to perform a particular function or set
of functions and software architecture
in practice says the software
architecture is that program is the
structure or the structures of program
which enable the elements to be
connected together and the relationships
between them so what's the goals of
architecture when it involves various
people various parties the stakeholders
the business goals as well and also the
IT infrastructure which needs to support
it as DevOps the IT infrastructure is
the most important aspect of it but
there are the other two to take into
account as DevOps will be concerned with
building the infrastructure to support
the architecture that's required so an
IT architecture what is it where its
rules and guidelines and patterns
assisted development so going to manage
the problem as a series of discrete
pieces we need to define the
communication interfaces between the
pieces we need to think about the
overall structure and how data flows we
need to integrate the various systems
and subsystems in the environment
together we need to develop software
modules on the best possible design
practices and design patterns need to
control delivery of software into the
system environment effectively and
efficiently and reliably so this
compares architecture and design
architecture is more strategic Rather's
design is tactical the important word in
architecture is how how do things fit
together rather than what do we use to
connect things together we look at
programming paradigms and architectural
patterns high level patterns rather than
algorithms and low-level patterns
we're looking at the non-functional
requirements architecture is a
non-functional requirement if a
statement of these systems are going to
communicate in this way whereas design
is concerned with the function
requirements what does the system
actually do and in UML the diagramming
language we have certain diagrams which
are more associated with architecture
than those that are you use for design
so let's look at some architectural
patterns the client-server architecture
plasma has been around for some time the
idea is we have a thick client which
communicates across the network with
some external data storage the thick
client has the user interface the
business logic and the data access layer
all in the same unit of functionality so
the advantage of this is we basically
separate all of the code from the the
data it enables the server components to
be reused the server components and
managing is some central location and we
can optimize the use of infrastructure
it's also quite scalable so the
advantage of this is we basically
separate all of the code from the the
data it enables the server components to
be reused the server components are
managed to some central location and we
can optimize the use of infrastructure
it's also quite scalable the problem is
it doesn't work well with the
requirements changes there are security
issues as well associated with it
is a single point of failure which means
the whole system becomes on available if
the one component fails we've also got
the presentation and business logic in
the same place which is not a good idea
it's also quite difficult to test and
scale in terms of the thick client
another pattern which is very popular is
the interior architecture where any the
number which is usually 3 the great
advantage of this is it's completely
multi-threaded so the the middle layers
can be executed in parallel so multiple
clients can each have their own threads
executing it if the business logic
changes we don't need to change the the
user interface client code typically the
client is a very thin client such as a
web browser we reduce the network
traffic dramatically because most of the
network traffic is happening between the
layers and we can add additional layers
or tiers for various purposes to add
layers of traction and failover
disadvantage if requirements change we
need to change quite a bit it may be in
the middle tiers the security
implications are quite interesting as
well because the can be problems
associated with the access from the
external sources
we still got server availability and
reliability issues and we've still got
testability and scalability issues
service-oriented architectures are
becoming increasingly popular they have
a great number of advantages probably
the most important one is loose coupling
we have components which can be written
in different languages operating in
different environments which can
communicate with each other seamlessly
without having to worry about the
details we've got business services can
be spread across lots of different
platforms and you just use the service
you need as and when you need it we
don't need to know where anything is it
can be anywhere within the corporate
network or within the cloud and we don't
need to know what the exact location
because the infrastructure takes care of
it we can reuse services if you've got a
legacy application what you can do is
put a service-oriented front-end on it
and then it becomes part of a
service-oriented architecture it which
you see development costs and increases
development speed and it's easier to
integrate the business and the IT
environments there are some
disadvantages
it's quite difficult to migrate because
there's so many moving parts you need
very good control you need very good
auditing and monitoring systems and
probably the hardest one is getting the
development and design correct how the
pieces fit together
how they communicate with each other
what series of operations is required to
achieve a particular business goal many
people and organizations these days are
going towards rest micro-services it's a
good foundation for many api designs
rest is actually not a new idea it's
been around since 1996 when the HTTP
protocol was first devised basically the
world wide web is a good example of a
restful service so the architecture has
evolved over time the web itself has
evolved massively over the 20 years
experience existence it focuses on
resources and information and NOC code
what you do when you talk to a rest
service is you ask for a representation
of information not for the actual data
itself so components can evolve
separately it's very highly scalable you
just add other services development
costs is greatly reduced because each
piece is a fairly small unit of
functionality and it makes data imported
it exposes data as a resource and
requires a separate way of representing
data the data and the code are not
considered connected the data is stored
somewhere in some form the code delivers
the data in some representational form
the disadvantages a lot of people are
not familiar with the approach and
infrastructures are not really geared up
to deal with it although that is getting
better it also requires a very
significant change in the way that
developers think about how things
interoperate another architectural model
is the four plus one view which is quite
an interesting concept the idea is that
different people and teams have
different views of systems so for
example you got the logical view is how
the end-user sees a system which is in
terms of its actual functionality you've
got the development view which is a
developer's seat what are the actual
software components and how they
interact
you've got the process view which is
watch the actual processes and how do
they communicate with each other and
you've got the physical view or
deployment view which is where the
software actually resides on what
hardware and what location and so each
of those four views gives you a slightly
different picture of the system so the
full force one architectural view says
okay we'll take these four views and
then generate the fifth view the plus
one which is the use cases which take
these solutions from the four views and
combine them together into a single view
Center use cases hey once become an
expert in cloud computing then subscribe
the simpler Channel and click here to
watch more such videos turner it up and
get certified in cloud computing click
here